work with uh defenso
shang chan and chuan juan gu who are all
at ucla
i'm just going to jump into it because i
don't have much time
um so there's a lot of self-training
algorithms the one i'm going to be
talking about is one of self-training
with pseudo-labelers so pseudo-labelers
are just classifiers it's just a fancy
way of saying that where you generate
labels for unlabeled data by just using
the output of that classifier
and the procedure that
is one of the common procedures for this
algorithm is to
assume you have access to some small
label data sets and some larger
unlabeled data set
and you perform supervised learning on
that small label data set to learn some
initial pseudo-labeler
that's what we'll call beta pl and beta
pl is used to generate
labels for your unlabeled data
and then you feed in those uh pseudo
labels
into
like a supervised learning algorithm
that uses the unlabeled data and the
pseudolabels from that came from the
prediction from beta pl
and then you run supervised learning you
update the classifier at every iteration
generate new pseudo-labels using that
new pseudo-labeler
and the potential benefit for this is
that it allows for you to get away with
you leveraging these large unlabeled
data sets
right the the kind of catches
is this going to work like we'll
actually be able to learn the optimal
classifier and what are the conditions
under which we could expect such a thing
to happen
um
so something that's you know been shown
in a variety of vision models and in
other settings is that this does
actually work it is able to help improve
performance on a number of metrics
um especially in envision tests like on
predicting imagenet
um and so the kind of question that i'll
be talking about is whether or not is
trying to characterize the sample
complexity
of uh this standard self-training
algorithm both from trying to understand
how many labeled examples do you need in
order to jump start this process
and whether or not you can learn the
optimal classifier and how many
unlabeled examples you might need to do
that
so the distribution that we'll be uh
considering
is a mixture model so we have two
cluster means at mu and minus mu
um and we assume that the mixture
distribution or the cluster
distributions are isotropic rotationally
symmetric and log concave
so in this setting
uh you can show that the bayes optimal
classifier for the distribution is just
the linear classifier given by
the taking the output of
the sign of the mean dot product with
the feature
so we'll want to kind of compare
performance of whatever the algorithm is
to whatever the performance of that
classifier is
this is something just to keep in mind
we have isotropic clusters
and we're not going to make assumptions
on the separation between them
so you could have a very high overlap
between them in which case this bayes
optimal classifier is not going to
perform very well
just something to keep in mind
and so here's the kind of gory details
of what this what this algorithm looks
like
all right so we start with some uh
initial classifier beta pl
um and at each step we're going to be
performing a kind of online sgd with a
relatively large batch size
so we have this unlabeled data that's
iid at each iteration
generate the pseudo-labelers using by
pseudo labels using the current
pseudo-labeler
and the update that we do is a kind of
weight normalized gradient descent
so something i notice is that
we're differentiating uh through the
normalization
and
because the pseudo labels are really
just the sign of the predictions you're
going to get an absolute value term that
appears
right so you have kind of two sources of
non-complexity
one that comes from the absolute value
one that comes through different
differentiating through the uh
normalization
um and this is an important thing
because
you know because we have this absolute
value
if you didn't have any normalization you
could just drive that unsupervised loss
to zero just by taking the norm of the
predictor to infinity
so some type of regularization seems
necessary and so that's why we are
including this weight normalization term
okay so we're getting on the setup
because next i'll go into
uh what the results are
okay
okay so uh the main result is that so in
this mixer model setting i just
described there's some universal
constant c error such that as long as
the initial pseudo-labeler that you use
has a classification or smaller than
that absolute constant
than the self-trading algorithm that's
initialized at that pseudo-labeler and
using a total of d over epsilon squared
unlabeled examples its devices to get
with an epsilon error of the bayes
optimal error
and so we need a batch size of like
order 1 over epsilon a runtime of d over
epsilon and so that's where the
unlabeled sample complexity comes from
and so the kind of tagline is that
self-training converts weak learners in
the sense that you get constant error
initially
to strong learners to getting with an
epsilon of the optimal error using only
unlabeled examples
and so you might ask like what's the
catch
and the catch is how do you start this
algorithm
that is able to get that constant error
that's necessary to jumpstart this
and that's what our next result will
describe
so so in order to jump start
the cell training algorithm on the last
last result
we do need to have that the mixture
models are somewhat more separated that
there's some constant that the mean is
bigger than that constant
but i can again keep in mind the
separation
uh you know it's
isotropic clusters so we're not having a
dependence on the dimension in terms of
separation it's just a constant
um but in this in this setting the kind
of standard supervised approach for
uh linear class
for linear classification is just to do
standard gradient descent on the
legislative clause without any
normalization
and if you run this in this setting then
you can output a classifier that has a
classification error smaller than that
constant
so
questions first to get these
right
yes yeah that's
okay so and the other question
this distribution is the property that
if you just look at you can identify
something if you don't eliminate them if
you have interference
right it's just a place for architecture
but uh so in that sense
it's kind of an easy case what happens
if you have a spherically symmetric
distribution
there's no
of the
x-rays seeking out
yeah that's that's a good question it's
not
so it's not it's not clear to me
the extent to which that's possible i
mean i'll get into the kind of proof
idea shortly where it might it might be
possible in some settings
um but our proof does rely on the the
fact that there is this structure of the
mixture distribution so that allows for
uh getting around it but but i guess
also i just want to emphasize that
the question is you know if you have
infinite labeled examples then yes the
problem is easy but like how many
labeled examples do you need in order to
to start a self-training algorithm that
can
be found
uh yeah
that's that's true yes um so i guess
it is a it is a toy model for which
there are you know more efficient
algorithms for learning it um
but i guess the interest is in seeing
whether or not this non-convex
optimization problem that's used in
practice has concept can have
uh you know
somewhat good labeled sample complexity
for related problems
so i assume that there are assumptions
that the two mixtures the labels
completely line with the two components
of the mixture
yeah
because so basically the answer already
have the information
if i cut it
there's no align then i don't think this
should work
yeah i mean it i mean i guess it does
work in
in practice and complicated distribution
so i feel like there might be some
settings in which
there are reasonable
distributional assumptions that still
result in this behavior
um i guess i'm trying to understand how
much the unlikely data structure has to
help you somehow it doesn't then
shouldn't work
yeah i think i think there has to be
some sense in which the only there is
structure to the unlabeled data because
otherwise you can't hope to learn using
just an unsupervised approach
okay and so just the kind of corollary
to to this result is that you know if as
long as the mixtures are separated by
some constant
then this
uh semi-supervised self-training
approach can learn the bayes optimal
classifier using a or you know constant
with respect to epsilon labeled examples
and uh
d of wraps on squared unlabeled examples
so the kind of core the proof idea and
and maybe why i think it might have some
uh there might be some insight that
could be used in other settings
it's about uh identifying that
if you can essentially treat because the
problem with uh self-training is that
you know you have these noisy labels
that are generated by a pseudo-labeler
that does not actually predict the
correct labels for the distribution
right it makes errors with some
proportion
but if you can have some algorithm which
is tolerant to
label noise in some sense
then it should work in the self training
uh and you should be able to get away
with using unlabeled examples in the
self training setting
and so why is that is because you know
you can imagine
the updates that you're doing in
gradient descent are essentially as if
you had come from a distribution where
the label there was some true generating
process where the labels came from the
pseudo-labeler but then those labels are
corrupted with some possibly instance
dependent probability right um so
you can just view it like initially the
labels come as the sine of beta x and
then you flip the sign with some
possibly instance dependent probability
and that's really all that the algorithm
is seeing and so if you have an
algorithm which is
uh can be tolerant to kind of a label
noise
then it stands to reason that you can
have some type of self-training
algorithm that is able to just use the
pseudo-labels that come from that
algorithm
and still be able to learn
and so this is kind of the
the proof idea and so we can utilize
some
proof techniques we're learning half
spaces with noise using gradient descent
to be able to
get around the noisy labels that come
from the super labeler
and then just one other component is how
do you get around the non-convexity
because you know we're differentiating
through that absolute value sign we're
also differentiating through uh the
normalization
um and the kind of high-level idea is
that we show that as long as the
classification error of the
pseudo-labeler is smaller than some
constant then you have this kind of
proxy convexity property
which essentially allows for you to say
that whenever the angle between the
predictor and the bayes optimal
predictor is large
then you will get closer to the bayes
optimal predictor
and so this is the kind of the real
technical meat of the proof is to be
able to show this type of inequality
it doesn't seem like the norm of mu
is important here
what role does it play in the sample
places uh it doesn't essentially play a
role at all
uh yeah so i guess i maybe i miss the
this is ben's point about the whether or
not they're separated enough so so you
know as you get a weaker and weaker
signal from the unlabeled data
you're not you're not seeing that play
the role
right
yeah that's true
so that that doesn't have to help i mean
it's nearly zero
or close to zero then there's no
information about that
that's right right i mean we have we
need to have mu is at least some cons
in order to jump start the supervised
learning so that you know that this you
know this constant is like say like 1
over 10
this
like there is some it requires there to
be some separation but like a constant
level of separation is sufficient but a
constant is pretty small when you're
considering isotropic models right
so it's in there
yeah it's kind of hidden in here and
that's what the supervised claim was
about
um i guess i'm about done uh yeah so
something i'm just interested in
exploring after this is whether or not
this idea that you know designing or
having analysis of algorithms that are
tolerant to label noise can lead to
guarantees using unlabeled data and what
this might and whether or not it's the
kind of very strong
structural assumptions that we make on
the joint distribution whether or not
those can be loosened in some way in in
these other algorithms that we know are
able to tolerate
i think it's likely um i haven't worked
out with it
where the error would what that error
would from our proof would introduce i
think it probably as long as there's
some separation then i think it would
probably be fine
and then that's my talk
so maybe one or two questions
[Music]
by far but how do you compare this with
boosting
you're kind of boosting something like a
weak learner and then but you're using
unlabeled data to boost
any connection at all
it's possible because we're not really
like combining the fact that
we're not really combining weak learners
to make a strong learner it's more that
the weak learner itself like as long as
the classification are small then you
have this kind of nice optimization
landscape
that allows for
kind of ignoring the label noise
basically what if i actually i do
combine
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure what that
would look like but it could it could
work and i'm not sure
i mean theory the unlabeled data is also
making the
the weak learner better life
so if i combine on top of that
yeah yeah i i'm not sure what it would
look like but i think it wouldn't be
able to get something tractable
are there connections to perhaps doing
like something like
a weak transductive learning
followed by
just supervised learning so if you have
a weak transductive learning guarantee
or unlabeled
uh labels on the unlabeled data are good
enough
like other connections there i'm not
sure yeah i i haven't thought about that
i'm not sure what what it would look
like in in this setting
yeah sorry yeah we can chat
[Music]
okay let's thank spencer again
[Applause]
session
lunch break now
one